hello everyone and welcome to what
appears to be another brilliancy from
the IRA flawed open who we already
checked out one game and well that one
wasn't really in C but this one it's
it's something else it's it's again
between now in a grandmaster from Iran
partner max Hulu who needs no
introduction currently rated at 2674
plays against international master from
Azerbaijan I didn't swim monthly yeah
just was thinking about something there
ah international master from Azerbaijan
I didn't swim only who is 14 years old
at the time and it's really just
impressive it's the penultimate round
and the outcome of this game will will
have a lot to do with the final
standings so without further ado let's
check out this brilliancy Max Weber
opens with c4 at the English opening we
have 60 iron core defense Knight to c3
d5 and would be for we transpose into
the Queens gambit declined and Bishop to
e7 now adult Petrosyan defense we have
seek after sandy 5s he captures and
Bishop to f/4 now as the bishop is now
guarding the g5 square black postponed
the development of the night a bit and
Knight to f6 now defending the adding
more the defense to the pawn developing
and preparing the castle III and now
Bishop to f5 by black and now as the
Bishop left the defense of the b7 pawn
Matsui will use this to develop the
Queen with tempo Queen b3 attacks the
pawn on b7 and just Knight to c6 it's a
well known a well known pawn pawn
sacrifice in this position Queen
captures on b7 and now the only move
that really gives a black any
compensation for the sacrifice pawn that
is nice to be for threatening night to
see to check to pick up the rook we have
looked the c1 Bishop to b5 check is also
possible this will be followed by King
to f8 and then the game continues pretty
much the same roof to c1 where black
will be denied castling privileges
although black will play some like g6
King g7 and Castle artificially later on
so rook the C 1 MUX Lulu doesn't think
this is necessary so he just
prevents night to see to check we
castles by solar modeling in the now
Queen captures on c7 much suitable grabs
another pawn we have Queen captures on
c7 Bishop captures and now rook F the c8
so mock Zulu is up two points if he can
consolidate if he can develop the Kings
side then he should be well he should be
just winning so Bishop back to f4 not
going all the way to g3 so Knight to e4
doesn't come with an attack on the
bishop Knight to e4 still you cannot
capture because the rook would hang on
c1 and also you're threatening to
capture here then you're threatening to
capture here your your winning back at
least one pawn and now there is one game
where g4 was played but here f3 is a new
move by Mac Zulu
so already has removed 13 we have a
completely new game also possible
something like a three but a3 is
incredibly complicated and you really
want to get rid of this knight on e4 you
you have to start developing your Kings
side here black can even reply with a
five and it's hard to save faith and we
actually did anything because if
characters captures this doesn't really
do anything for what you're gonna win
back your knight you there's no point in
playing some like 92 to defend the rook
as well is it simply doesn't do all that
much for example if you move the knight
Knight c2e2 just rook captures Knight
captures and then you again adjust
attack and rook to a-1 King to d1 but
now the night comes into play of course
Knight captures an f2 with check picks
up the other rook so there's that but
it's only only if after this a5 is
played which is not a necessity so
really really a complicated move a 3
here so max will look at this size for
f3
we have Knight captures and c3 now not
rook characters if rook captures the
knight captures here and after captures
captures it's again you still haven't
developed anything
rook the c1 is coming Bishop to b4 check
is in the air a lot of a lot of very
strong moves here so after Knight
captures and c3b captures and then now
not going for a nightcap resonate you
because if Knight captures on a2 then
Luke a1 attacks the knight Knight
captures on c3 yes you win back some
material
but the bishop to a6 goes after the rook
you're gonna continue with 92 and you
you will survive this
so instead after Big B captures in c3
soleymani goes for g5 so what happens
here okay Bishop to g3 you just move the
Russia back and now a5 still waiting
with the capture on a - so what can what
can you play here well if a three-night
the C to check is always an option so
white really has to decide what to do
here max willow goes for a 4 so what
what happens next we have nice - a - now
attacking the rook and the c3 pawn rook
the a1 and now Knight captures in c3
again white still white still has to
develop his King side and he's not doing
a great job at it so nice - E - he has
to start developing it but now Bishop to
b4 again preventing easy development
because after captures captures you just
lose more material due to check so King
back to f2 and now comes now comes a
very nice move Bishop the c2 goes after
the pond
sulemani wants to get rid of the spawn
and create a past a pond so he can start
pushing it so if you don't want to lose
it Knight captures and C 3 we have
Bishop captures and the now comes as the
rook is under attack rook to a2 so now
even feel free to pause the video how
would you continue this position you
don't want to give white any time to
consolidate feel free to pause the video
while I give you a couple of seconds so
for those of you who were able to do it
congratulations and continuing to
harassing the rook so and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it's
bishop the b1 so now the rook is under
attack and it's not it's not all that
clear or where you want to go with the
rook rook the e2 was played by Maxwell
he tried to keep everything but rook to
e2 as you can see just blocks in this
Bishop you cannot develop the bishop if
you don't develop the bishop you cannot
develop the rook so one way you could
have gone about this is a rook to a3 but
then after the the rook is a attacked
for example a bishop to a3 now you have
have to move the rook well you can't
move the rook actually you'd have to
play something like Bishop to e2 and
then trade rook for Bishop you are up up
some points so maybe just give up the
exchange because if you move the rook
let's say rook the b3 then you have Luke
the c2 with check bushel blocks and then
just the bishop to a2 again traps the
rook so okay okay Rudy three and then
Bishop c4 traps it which is now
completely losing for white so you you
should definitely try something but it's
not at all clear why so what so here max
ulu goes back Luke the e2 but this is
just ugly how are you how are you gonna
develop anything and now rook the c4
again continuing with the plan going
after the e4 pawn which will create the
past a pawn and now again you could try
something like h4 or something just just
to try and open up your position but
here look the c2 was played by max will
go it's it's a really an interesting
move it just seems like like a terrible
blunder but it's it kind of is but it's
not so once again feel free to pause the
video here and try to find the winning
move for so a manly while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
on not capturing the rook capturing the
rook isn't the best so for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show the move
is Bishop the e1 check and you just pick
up a clean rope here well not a clean
work the exchange but point is if you
capture the rook then you have Bishop
captures on c4 pawn captures in the rook
the c1 will pick up one of the bishops
so after Bishop capture 784 you're gonna
capture here and now after Bishop e3 you
prepare to push your past pawn
Bishop to b6 and now after a four you
just block with Bishop to a3 it's not an
easy align to spot however mocs will
have found it and that is why he played
this rook to c2 move and now you will
not be able to push any of the pawns
here it's a it's a drawn drawn endgame
so rook the c2 is is brill
you know it's it would be brilliant if
it wasn't losing on the spot but
Suleiman Lee found that he played Bishop
the
after work to see duty played Bishop the
e1 with trick now you have to capture it
King captures and I just rook captures
and c2 and now again it makes it really
difficult to develop pieces for example
Bishop d3 just runs into looks you want
check picks up the rook and this is
something white will not be able to
handle so h4 trying to open up the the
rooks file this way but now rook 8 the
c8 we have Bishop to d6 trying to block
this rook from entering the game but of
course Suleiman Leah just plays rook
rook a to the C 3 we have h captain g5
now the rook the rook can finally enter
the game however rook the b2 and it was
in this position that Parham ox will
resign the game and so a manly after 8
rounds is leading the IRA open which
which is pretty incredible as he's only
14 years old and it's an incredibly
strong tournament like I said he's rated
2474 and max Lewis 2674 so exactly 200
rating for the points apart between the
two of them so it's quite quite an upset
in the penultimate round of the iro foot
open so here he resigns in in you know
face of certain doom group to see one
will be checkmate and you can't really
do anything about it if Bishop here you
can just deliver check not not something
you want to do for example this you
deliver check and now of K if you block
just the bishop to you you can go for
material will Bishop the c2 but Bishop
to d3 is actually a force mating for so
not not much you can do here whatever
you do let's say but from g3 rook the e2
with check now you cannot capture
because the bishop is pinned king f1
look after sandy one and now after
Bishop blocks there's there's the mate
Bishop to g3 is only a prolong and since
that's why it's a mating for otherwise
it would be an 18-3 and if you don't if
you play something like king d1 instead
then it's a bit of a different bit of a
different winning a pattern but just
bishop a 2 2 B 3 will do the job Bishop
e2
now whatever there should be 2 you have
to create some room for a king but
should be 3 checking you want now you
deliver Turkey
if - now I just pick up the rook yup a
whole rook of course completely winning
for black Austria after rook to be tumor
MUX will resign the game and we'll see
if how swimmingly will do in the final
round of the IRA float open and we'll be
able to take first place which were
which would be just just incredible so
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it as a lot of you have
requested that I would like to thank
Frank combs at a certain Patsy's Neil
Chapman Emig well arambula and robert
garcia for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot - really appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the Paul Morphy saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and of course whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day